je vous préviens j'ai fait picard allait
commencer je vais tourner la salade
jacques picard pour un repas de famille
je suis content d'annoncer son bord -
ouais c'est pas folichon superbe à votre
tour kolda cpie cas je peux vous dire
que ce niveau là c'est surtout utile au
fond de boulot à qui ça s'est fait tout
seul a normalement de deux choses l'une
soit tu l'as fait soit ces picards
non mais maman tu l'as acheté dans les
magasins tu as payé tu as ouvert le
paquet ou la réchauffer
tu te souviens de tout ça mais qu'est ce
vous arrive tous aujourd'hui vous n'êtes
pas bien c'est pas passer ma journée
dans la cuisine pour m'entendre dire que
j'ai fait réchauffer au micro-ondes ca
meilleur
vous aimez passer à des plats pic à moi
je suis super fan de l'arrouza cas avec
anne on voit la moussaka ces grecs c'est
pas du tout picard là vous êtes tous 101
c'est qu'une flammèche une tourte
picarde n'avons pas j'ai passé ma
journée à faire c'est ce que je dis
c'est une toulouse picarde de picardie
c'est une recette de ma cousine damien
devient chez bear entreprenons par une
femme ma cousine rose
damien en pis et renée ok mais vous
l'avez connu ma cousine rose à amiens
derrière la cathédrale
oui oui oui mais d'accord mais pourquoi
mais je ne te le diront mieux maintenant
tu sais tu finis puis tes phrases en
face à la gauche la rue du rugueux comme
la famille dormait rue le coco voit la
rue
d'ailleurs vous m'avez et puisse être en
face à lui